hello guys and welcome back to
jaegerists
in today's video we will be going
through the story of porco galliard
leave a like on this video and subscribe
to our channel if you want to see more
content like this
some years before the paradis island
operation porco was a leading candidate
to inherit the armored titan
he participated in the selection process
along other eldian children
he and his older brother marcel were
chosen to be candidates for warriors
after an extenuating physical test
involving
running under the reign with military
equipment after reuniting with the other
six possible candidates and receiving
the information about the future
offensive against paradise island
porco scolded reiner braun as he
considered him the only one without a
special talent
being only fueled by his love towards
marley and his adulating towards his
superiors
after reiner accused him of being an
aldean spy porco punched him and was
stopped by his brother before continuing
to their destination
even though marcel had convinced him to
stop the assault porco continued to mock
reiner
it was eventually decided in the year
843 that reiner would inherit the power
of the armored titan
porco's brother marcel was additionally
chosen to inherit the power of the jaw
titan
when the warriors departed for paradis
island porco remained behind on the
continental mainland
when the paradis island operation is
abandoned in the year 850
amir who had eaten marcel and stolen the
power of the jaw titan
is sent back to marley afterward porco
is chosen to reclaim the jaw titan from
marley
porco consumes amir and gains the power
of the titans
four years after the warriors return
porco is present at the battle of fort
slava
under orders from the warriors marley
and superiors led by commander mcgoth
he along with his comrade piek are
unauthorized to engage in combat with
the mideast allied forces at the fort
due to the presence of the highly
dangerous anti-titan artillery
however once gabby succeeds in bombing
the armored train which held the
artillery
porco joins the fight and shields her
and falco from machine gun fire before
charging forward
decimating the enemy's defenses after
clearing the defenses
porco keeps advancing towards the enemy
killing several soldiers inside the
trenches and using his powerful jaw to
break the railways
after the armored titan is deployed
inside the fortress he destroys several
anti-titan artillery platforms in order
to protect him
he quickly retires and leaves the
remaining soldiers to the armored titan
and the beast titan
after the battle porco watches over
reiner as he recovers from his injuries
following the battle of fort slava
when reiner awakens he thanks porco for
saving him in fort slava
but porco coldly tells him that he only
wanted to keep marley from losing the
armored titan
porco then explains that he did not
inherit his brother's memories but he
did inherit
amir's memories and harshly berates
reiner for needing to be saved by his
comrades so often
including marcel whose death porco holds
reiner accountable for
reiner eventually leaves after piek
joins them porco later joins the rest of
the marlin military on the train
returning to their homeland
seated among the other warriors after
arriving at liberio
porco is seen helping colt walking since
he is suffering from a hangover
after entering into the internment zone
he is greeted by a man and a woman
porko is soon summoned to the warriors
headquarters for a meeting with zeke
on his way he meets up with piek who is
trying to walk on all fours to emulate
her cart titan
once the two arrive zeke informs them of
his plan to stabilize marley's steadily
waning power
by recommending the paradis island
operation to reclaim the founding titan
porco is unhappy at the news that the
noble tiber family will be
acting as the warriors spokespersons
during the affair but is convinced by
reiner and zeke to agree
to the plan porco quietly attends a
military meeting figuring out the
logistics of an invasion of paradise
island
after the meeting ends he joins his
warrior colleagues outside on a balcony
and sarcastically complements the senior
officers as wise
when falco overtakes gabby in a foot
race and cold expresses that gabby's
superior ranking will not change
corco calls the selection criteria vague
porco along with the other warriors are
instructed to take a seat before willy
typer's speech
as ambassadors to marley after taking
their seat a marley soldier informs the
warriors that mcgoth wants to speak with
them
after sending zeke off the soldier leads
porko and piek to an empty room
confused porco asks where magoth is only
for the soldier to cut a nearby rope
opening a trap door underneath the two
porco and piak fall onto a bed of straw
fracturing their bones in the process
piek identifies the hole as an
old-fashioned warrior confinement area
and they note the lack of space to
transform
porko wonders about the soldier's plan
piek answering that she is not sure
but recognizes the soldier from
somewhere the captive warriors begin to
feel tremors inside the confinement trap
this allows piek to deduce that the
titans are battling outside giving
reason to why they were captured
as porco begins questioning how to
escape the panzer unit comes to the
rescue
piek explains that she had taken
security messers because of the
suspicious feeling she had gotten from
their supposed escort
the unit then sends down a rope which
the warriors used to climb up and out of
the pitfall
the rescuers informed them about the
attack titan's sudden appearance and how
the warhammer titan is currently
engaging it in battle
will spiek briefs her troops porco
prepares to go and join the fray
though she asks him to stop and observe
the situation for a while
porco is then shocked to see a group of
soldiers dart over them using
anti-personal vertical maneuvering
equipment
having never seen it used before porco
eventually separates from piek and
after transforming into his jaw titan
joins the battle
he sneaks up on aaron jaeger's attack
titan from behind and leaps onto its
nape
distracting him and ultimately saving
the younger sister of willy from getting
consumed
forko then bites down into the neck of
the attack titan remarking that he has
always waited for the moment he could
retake the founder back for marley
when he is unable to bite through he is
left confused unaware that a soldier
had slashed the muscles on the left side
of his titan's face the attack titan
then smashes porco on a building behind
them
and as he sees the soldier maneuvering
around he fearfully realizes that it is
an ackerman
acknowledging the danger he is now in
porco tries to escape after chipping
away at the attack titan's arm
but is quickly struck with a thunder
spear this brings him crashing into the
ground
porco is soon surrounded by numerous
survey corps soldiers
he is bewildered that a bunch of humans
have been able to stun him while in his
titan form and are trying to kill him
he then realizes the soldiers attacking
him are the devils of paradise island
pxcart titan then arrives in time with
the panzer unit killing several enemy
soldiers with his machine guns much to
porco's surprise
as the beast titan also joins the
battlefield porco and px stand by its
side
facing the rest of the survey core as an
enemy soldier flies above the cart titan
ready to strike
porco spots them and leaps up in the air
he manages to kill the soldier to px
relief and flings the corpse away
he partially emerges from his titan and
warns piek of the ackermann as they had
lost sight of him
he listens as piek assesses the
situation and he states if they could
get the founding titan
the enemy would lose the ace up their
sleeves they are interrupted by a sudden
massive explosion of the harper
piek recognizes it as coming from the
colossus titan and realizes berthold was
killed and had his titan ability taken
by the enemy
angered by this porco once again charges
at aaron yeager remarking that the
enemy's plans
would be ruined if he gets rid of him
seeing another ackermann in his way
porco lunges at her as she reads her
blades to engage him porko is stunned to
see zeke's titan get taken down by levi
and then sees that the kart titan is
disabled as well fearing that both have
been killed
this drives him into a rage once more
and targets aaron growing out the claws
on his titan form
porco avoids another attack by mikasa
and lunges at the attack titan
only to get punched in the face despite
this
porco hangs on and bites down on the
hardened fist made by aaron
he then rakes the face of the attack
titan with numerous strikes one getting
deflected by the crystals surrounding
the younger sister of willy
porco momentarily retreats back to the
husk of the warhammer titan
noticing an incoming airship porco
realizes that is how the survey corps
plan to retreat
he changes targets but fails to see
mikasa who cripples his titan by slicing
through his legs and cutting off his
right foot
this sends borco crashing down in front
of aaron the latter subdues the jaw
titan by tearing off both its arms and
forces the crystal into its mouth
forko realizes the attack titan wishes
to use him to steal the warhammer titan
but is unable to stop it
he is forced by aaron to bite down and
break through the hardened crystal
killing the younger sister of willy and
allowing aaron to obtain her titan
powers
he is then slammed to the ground and
left unconscious by aaron who tries to
bite his nape and eat him as well
seeing this gabby and falco yell for
reiner to save him
eventually managing to awaken him reiner
appears in an unarmored titan form and
takes porco away from aaron before being
punched and knocked down
too aaron stops his attempts of eating
porko and fleas the scene with mikasa
some time after the battle finishes
porco sits with a recovered piek
drinking alcohol when reiner wakes up
porco asks him if he had had a nightmare
not waiting for a response he passes a
bottle to reiner wishing their current
situation was just a bad dream
porco later takes part in an emergency
meeting with magoth and the other
warriors
he is shocked to hear that zeke is most
likely working with paradis and deceived
all of marley
as part of the retaliation against
paradis porco and piek are sent to
infiltrate paradise's military the two
infiltrate the military headquarters
where aaron yeager is staying
and porco stands by in a survey corps
disguise while piek leads him to the
roof
once piek has brought aaron to the roof
of the building porco transforms into
his jaw titan form and ambushes aaron
but is unable to prevent
aaron from transforming as aaron
transforms porco uses the jaw titan to
shield piek and gabby from the resulting
blast
on px orders porco cuts off her arm and
uses his own titan to distract aaron as
she transforms
once piek has fled with gappy porco
falls back to a safe distance himself
as reiner engages aaron in his armored
titan form porco tries to attack aaron
from behind
determined to get revenge for being made
an accomplice in the warhammer titans
murder he avoids an initial attack from
aaron
but he and reiner are both skewered and
left immobile when aaron begins creating
hardened structures from the ground
porco manages to free himself from the
spike he is skewered on and tries to
attack aaron again
but is forced to retreat as eren creates
more spikes porco goes in for an attack
again as reiner grapples with aaron
but aaron easily smacks him out of the
air knocking him into a row of nearby
buildings
still out of combat he witnesses the
arrival of zeke to the battlefield but
manages to recover
he tries to attack aaron again but is
caught in the middle of a barrage of
stones thrown from the beast titan
taking porco down once again seeing
aaron try to approach zeke's beast's
titan
porco grabs the attack titan and bites
down on its leg only to be struck
repeatedly in the nape by the attack
titan's hardened fists
and left severely wounded as reiner
fights aaron
he yells at porco to wake up and assist
him when he reaches to grab porco the
latter receives the memory of marcel
telling reiner that he sabotaged his
brother in order to save him from
becoming a warrior
de porco's shock and dismay soon porco
realizes that he is unable to heal all
his wounds and exits the jaw titan
stumbling towards reiner and a newly
transformed falco grease
he states how he finally was able to see
his brother's memories
and is now aware of marcel's role in him
not being selected as the armored titan
11 years prior proclaiming that he will
always be a better warrior than reiner
porco allows himself to be devoured by
falco and transfers his power to the
young warrior candidate
porco is one of the many titan
inheritors whose titan is created by
amir fritz to defend aaron while he is
attempting to rumble the world
his titan attacks reiner using its claws
to slash his titan's face until connie
springer blows it away with a
thundersphere
in the middle of the fighting porco and
a handful of other inheritors are
reawakened in the path world by zeke
zeke asks porko and the other inheritors
to lend their strength to him
and his allies taking control of his
titan porco helps fend off the myriad
titans that are attempting to defend
aaron he and marcel save gene kirsten
and piek from being killed
and continue the fight until aaron's
nape is destroyed
thank you guys so much for watching this
video it really means a lot to us
we will see you guys very soon in one of
our next videos